okay yeah what you made me do I am
wearing there we go pressing claim no it
started it started oh my god it sounds
so magical it's not so magical she's
singing no [ __ ] way she talking about
oh good she the gun
that's for Kim that one took you it's so
good oh my god I can't wait to see this
live oh okay
now the bees really draw see somehow
it's cool yeah this beam is really sick
though this doesn't sound like normal
Taylor Swift but I'm a huge fan of those
I'm so here for this I'm so alive for
this oh my god Oh classic I did not
expect this at all oh holy macaroni with
a piece of diamonds in it it's
definitely like a Dancy song it's so
good I don't know what I'm doing holy
[ __ ] gets like super upbeat and super
like real Katy Perry this is for you
yeah this is gonna be a dark album you
can tell okay like a fairy tale
wow so much shade this is crazy I'm
joking I'm a little bit afraid of her
right now
oh she is pissed off this is good
alright it's building up someone's
coming up
[Music]
look what you made me do Taylor oh my
god oh my god is it done
damn it's very weird I like it I'm so
glad you're back I missed you so much I
love you oh that's just happening I
don't even know what to say I had to
listen to that again
[Music]